welcome to another edition of the gadget
lab show i'm michael colori and i am
robert
a big news in the e-reader space this
week amazon has announced that it is
sold out of the kindle fire no more
kindle fires no more kindle fire and
there is an amazon event next week which
means
new kindles new kindles uh definitely
get a new kindle fire because definitely
you put money on that money i'm putting
all the money in my pocket which is
about eight bucks on that assertion um
we're also probably gonna be getting new
kindle touches because those have been
sold out for about a week or two
unavailable currently unavailable you
can't get a kindle touch which i don't
really care because my favorite uh
e-readers don't have touch same here
same here i'm using them oftentimes when
my thumb has to like they're so small
there's not really much of a bezel
your thumb actually goes on the screen
more than you'd think it would before
you buy one a touch device so i prefer
the buttons yes i do prefer the buttons
and that's one of the problems with the
kindles
is the buttons they move them from the
bezel to these to the edge
which is it's awkward to reach those
uh the nook on the other hand has the
buttons on the bezel and it has a light
which we're expecting from amazon's
offerings uh next thursday no this is
not this is not a backlight we should
they're front lit and most of the the
the ones probably amazon will probably
have a front lit one as well who knows
right who knows about us we don't know
what they're doing
uh but you can like push the button you
know forward and back and read it now
and the light turns on and off and the
light turns on and off so
this is great if you read at night i i
read at night before i go to bed um
and before all that sony reminded
everybody that they also have
an e-reader they have the uh i have to
look the prs-t2
it's commonly known as the sony reader
but we just like making fun of them for
their cryptic names
absolutely everything so this is their
new e-reader it's it's touch-based it
doesn't have buttons on the bezel or on
the side or anything i guess they figure
because it's touch-based you could just
do it with your finger go to the next
page they also have
they have the buttons down here instead
the physical buttons for the people who
don't want to live in the future yeah in
case you're afraid
so it's a pretty you know with with with
the nook out which already has the light
and the kindle being refreshed probably
the entire line except for maybe the dx
because no one cares about the dx
it's a weird time for sony to bring this
out and it not be like cutting edge
right kind of playing catch up right now
with this so you've been you've been
using this for about a week i have been
using your what are your impressions of
it you say it's not cutting edge but
it's you know it it's the the screen
compared to the nook and the kindle the
screen is crisper but
i'm seeing more artifacts when i when i
uh
so when i go to the next page i see
residual like little ghosts yeah a
little ghosting which kind of pulls you
out of
reading and when you're reading you want
to be immersed you just want to read you
don't you know want pages that you can
see other words on now if i understand
correctly this has to do with how
sony is implementing garbage collection
on the e-ink screen right yeah it's like
when they do a page refresh they can
either
take
everything off
and then put everything on
and show you a brand new clean page but
that takes longer right so they do kind
of a quickie kind of dirty refresh which
seems a lot snappier but leaves some of
those artifacts behind yeah you know the
the quickness in which a page turn is
it's it's so minut yeah that if i have
to wait a few extra milliseconds
that's that's fine it really bugs some
people something like oh my god like but
i'm talking about milliseconds i'm not
talking about like you know it's gonna
take four seconds this is this is a
problem that i found on the first
generation kindle dx
that's that's
years i don't know hundreds of years
away in the in the e-reader world um
so it's it's it's a little bit
disappointing well you know i think with
these things
even more important than the hardware is
the platform that it's tied to because
you're buying a piece of technology but
what you're putting onto it has so much
more to do with what's available in the
store and whether or not you can side
load is it internet connected things
like that so
and that in that respect what's your
favorite device like hardware wise
hardware wise the nook is my favorite
the the the back it has a little concave
the light the buttons right here the
best but
ecosystem and what i use it's the kindle
right i am sucked into the amazon
ecosystem i'm a prime member i can you
know i can share books i can get books
for free
the the amazon ecosystem is it's
unbelievable and it's it's unbeatable
right now it seems like my dad loves the
nook because they have better library
lending in his view the sony does have a
pretty sweet library lending um system i
haven't had a chance to test it though
okay that's one more thing but you know
from what they tell me it seems pretty
sweet compared to these other two so if
you're a big library nerd you don't care
about buying stuff and we should note
that um you will have a full review on
wired.com of the sony e-reader after
you've tested that and other numerous
things
coming up in the in the coming days and
also next week you will be in
well i was gonna say los angeles but
actually santa monica which is better
santa monica i will be in valley santa
monica thursday for the live blog i'll
be typing into my little fingers or down
to little nubs telling you everything
about the brand new kindles and maybe
just maybe an amazon phone not really
probably not
we're looking forward to that
uh and coming up next we have christina
who's going to give us a few details
about what's next in the apple samsung
dispute
so christine is here hi christina hi
mike you haven't been on the show in a
couple of weeks because you've been down
in san jose covering the apple v samsung
trial indeed the patent trial of the
century yes the the millennium so tell
us give us a very quick update on where
it stands right now right so after four
weeks of a jury trial the jury came to a
verdict that
samsung was infringing on apple's design
and
utility patents
28 of samsung's smartphones were found
to be infringing and apple was seeking a
preliminary injunction on eight of them
um but judge coe just recently ordered
that there's going to be no preliminary
injunction an injunction just means that
the products would be banned for sale in
the u.s
there's going to be no preliminary
injunction just a final injunction
hearing that will be held in in december
so we'll find out in december whether or
not they're going to have to actually go
pull samsung products from the radios
and the thing is none of these products
are super new like there's like the
samsung galaxy s2
there's a droid charge and a few other
older models can you even buy those off
the shelf at best buy anymore right i
don't yeah i mean by the time december
rolls around there's going to be like
100 new samsung models out there anyway
so i don't think it's going to hurt
samsung too much so you got to see most
of the proceedings right yeah definitely
the most interesting parts so uh tell us
some of the the cool stuff that you saw
like what were your impressions you know
of of the the big the big show yeah so
one of the most interesting things about
the case i thought was
uh the apple lawyers versus the samsung
lawyers and how they presented
themselves in their case uh the apple
lawyers were came across as very
friendly uh they were very practiced it
was almost like they were doing uh like
an apple media presentation like you
know when they introduced the iphone or
the ipad everything was just practiced
to a t it was
very relatable they broke everything
down into very simple terms so it was
super understandable
did they have keynote slides they did
they had slides it wasn't quite it
wasn't quite the apple keynote slides
but they did they used their slides
effectively
so samsung on the other hand they came
across as a lot more defensive kind of
abrasive a lot of the times they were
rebutting against what apple had just
said most of the time
um and then their whole case was just a
lot more complicated it was about you
know 3g transmission patents uh than
what apple had to deal with snoozer yeah
so it's much more complicated for the
jurors to try to understand all right so
what was the financial
award
so the jurors came to the conclusion
that samsung owes apple 1.05 billion
dollars is the injunction gonna have any
effect on that dollar amount or they
have to pay it no matter what so the
dollar amount that can get uh judge co
can actually up it by up to three times
that because the uh the jurors found
that the infringement was willful so it
could go up a whole bunch and then of
course samsung is appealing this so you
know once they go to the federal courts
they could get it lowered so it's kind
of up in the air could be more could be
less so however much money samsung is
going to be forced to pay apple at the
end of this uh is the company screwed at
this point
no i mean there's so much still up in
the air like basically nothing has been
decided yet the amount of money that
samsung owes is going to be fought over
for years and samsung doesn't have to
pay a dime until that's finally
finalized and then the phones that are
could possibly be banned for sale are
old phones anyway so that's not going to
kill samsung's you know economic outlook
or anything plus they're a pretty big
company they got a lot of collateral but
they could get a pretty solid loan at
about three and a quarter percent right
and also they still make chips for the
iphone so as long as the iphone's doing
well at least part of one of samsung's
many branches will continue making money
all right well either way your job is
not over anytime soon no this is going
to go on for years and years uh but the
show is coming to an end that's all the
the time we have time for this week or
something
we'll be back next week uh there will
probably be some apple news there will
probably be some amazon news and there
will probably be some microsoft news to
tell you about so
we will see you then next time on the
gadget lab